foreign
my name is Julius Jacob Shields I was
born in Lawrence Kansas
I'm from Kansas City Missouri
this is 11 years
I can't even say it this is 11 years
after the extraterrestrials made contact
with me
this is my story
all right so this was the first day
when they made the initial contact
I woken up that morning
gone to my window
opened it up
stretched my arms out and just said man
what a what a great day that's that's
something I've never done before
and then I closed the window kind of
turned the blinds a little bit and then
I sat down
got on the phone with my girlfriend
and uh
a few minutes later I see this like
it was almost like it was almost like a
balloon like it was just shaped like it
was almost like a balloon that you know
a little bit thicker of a string and
it's just going just back and forth very
I had a nice steady Pace just back and
forth across the wall and I'm
I don't even know I'm thinking maybe
it's like a shadow
maybe there's a bird flying around you
know something out there
uh
but then my my dog hunter
is now barking in that direction
in the direction where I'm sitting
like he's barking at somebody just
barking barking barking for you know
five ten minutes
and I'm just trying to
just listen to my girlfriend and just
enjoy a conversation
and I look back over
and on my door where there was the most
light
I saw I saw it it was about it was about
maybe about that big
they just had a body like this
eyes turned to the side
and I had three tentacles
and it raised them up
and started tapping on my window
and that was the first time I'd ever
seen something that wasn't
human
something I'd never seen before and
something I couldn't explain
and when I saw that I I just froze I
didn't make a move
it gets kind of blurry what happened but
I just know that I left my house
and I went to my buddy Nathan's that I
told them exactly what had just happened
and what I just saw
because this was 11 years ago obviously
I remember everything that happened in
that day so I'm going to go into the
next day
so the next night
sitting in my room on my bed
it's raining
and all over my window that's about you
know three four feet long I just hear
Taps from I mean every on every inch of
that window there was just Taps going on
which is impossible to be rained because
there's a deck over
over my windows so there's just no way
in hell that that's rain
and I immediately took off
and I went back to my buddy Nathan's
house
I told him what was going on man and
we went to bed on the third night
I'm sitting there
in my bed and I look over across the
room
and then there's just this horrible
light probably about about softball size
just the orbit light
I look over at it see it and it just
just floats off into my ceiling and is
gone
once again I fled
I did not know what else to do and what
I was experiencing all I knew was to
just flee and to just go find somewhere
else that was safe
now since this is years later I've had
plenty of time to think and analyze this
stuff
so what I believe happened is they
initially were like hey buddy you know
we're not from here we kind of want to
do some tests we don't know what you are
you don't know what we are like let's
you know let's let's figure out what we
are
and because I fled
they had no other option but to just
take me and do their tests
because it got so bad that I left the
basement after that third night I said
I'm not sleeping in the basement anymore
and I moved upstairs
to the upstairs room that's on
the outer edge of the house
so it goes room and then the outside
neighbor's house you know
and I would move up there and that
was when the abduction started
I don't know exactly when it started I
just know
that I would
go into these dreams
it started out more violent
like I would be in war in battle
in one specific dream I remember
as I woke up and I was in this like I
was in this Arena
Like Gladiator style and I'm looking
around and I just see all these
creatures and goblins and ghouls just
all in the stands and I don't know
what's going on
and then like this like teal
like blob monster just falls down in
front of me boom and a weapon spawned in
my hand and just instantly I just went
boom and just stabbed him and it was
like I I mean like I had just won I mean
the crowd went nuts
I felt like accomplished like I just won
something and then I and then I and then
I'd wake up in my bed and I'd hear the
sound
outside my room every single time I I
don't know if I can mimic it but it
almost did you just sound like a saucer
it was just like this
and and and it'd be gone
every time after these dreams
and then there was a a full week
straight because then it then it got
more then it got more sexual because
there was a full week straight where I
was having wet dreams every night I was
having sex with different creatures and
that were women and just different stuff
and I would wake up and
I would look at my pants and
sometimes there'd be nothing and
sometimes they would just it would it
would just be wet there would be no
actual sperm in there
uh
and I just I didn't know what to think
but I just knew that there was just
something going on because why
like why am I hearing this stuff why am
I having these dreams
you know I was scared for myself I
didn't know what was going to happen but
you know as the years progressed I
realized you know
for evolution you know this is amazing
you know these creatures came down
analyzed me figured out what I was what
I could do you know the different kind
of things I liked and liked to do you
know
and then
harvested my sperm and did whatever with
life
just went through evolution
oh now years later
I'll go on to meet my uncle thanks to my
wife I got reconnected with my uncle
Tylen uh
and you know we would talk I would talk
tell him about this stuff about what
happened to me all those years because
we would talk about how we grew up you
know and what we experienced and
different things and and I told him
about this and
and he froze
they almost didn't even know what to say
and then he revealed to me that
that he was having the same experiences
around the same time I was
he said it would be in these sedated
like dream state
but he said for him
he was having sex with like
whatever he wanted
like in his mind and he envisioned which
was like anime girls
that's what he told me that he was
having sex with those and he would wake
up and there would be nothing in his
shorts and he would know that he
ejaculated and he'd wake up and there
would be nothing
in his shorts and it's just amazing that
this could happen at the same time now
I've done my research on this stuff and
I know that what came to me they're
called the grays
they're not a very big creature
they're only they're only about three to
four feet tall
they drive saucers and they have a
Mothership and
it's almost astonishing
but it just makes you realize and just
know that there's just more to life than
just what we have here on Earth
and that's why I would take
use the rest of my life to travel and
experience as much as I can before it's
all over because
well there's definitely I'm not going to
go into what's beyond death but
in drugs weren't a part of your life
at that time I'm glad that time you know
marijuana was was playing big
it was just uh
it was the party thing you know me and
the boys that's hot that's how I grew up
was
was smoking weed and I and I know when
people are saying you know well
because I I was told that you know oh
well it was just we blah blah blah I
haven't stopped smoking weed since and
ain't nothing had like that ever
happened again
and then they wanted to try and say well
you know it was a possibility that you
know you're just schizophrenic okay well
schizophrenic don't just come and go it
don't just come for six months and then
I would have all these crazy experiences
and I would hear these sounds and and I
would actually see the thing on the wall
and then
you know schizophrenia just goes away no
that's not how that works so
yeah I've I've tried to arrive World out
everything but it's just the fact that
you know I saw it on the wall as my dog
was barking in the direction
and then I would hear the Taps on the
windows and then the orbs so they they
tried a
a more like Orthodox way to just be like
hey let's just reach out and just see if
he's willing to come with us
and do these experiments
and since I wasn't I was so scared and
so fearful they had to just take me and
just sedate me and just put me in a
dream like state
and it was so easy for them
because my bed was literally right next
to the wall
so it was so easy for them to just come
down
pull me over keep me in a dream life
State as soon as I was asleep
do these experiments whatever they
wanted to do and then just push me right
back and I would wake up and
and it would be like it was all a dream
but it was real because then how else
would my uncle be having the same
experience to be having
it's it's mind-boggling
and I I know for a fact
someone has done some research and has
known that there is a sort of
like UFO Highway sort of say
that goes right over Kansas City it goes
east to west across the United States
and it goes right through Kansas City
you're in a rural area or you were in a
busy like a more populated area
um I would say
it was just your regular neighborhood I
mean it was more of an elderly in the
neighborhood but no neighbors saw it
nothing like that
no nothing it was just the dog
so I don't
but it was early enough in the day that
nobody would have been awake
I mean the sun had the sun had just come
up and was just starting the day it was
just starting to get light out
and
so do you ever think about you know what
might have happened if you had decided
to go with them
because that seems to be what they
wanted right yeah I mean obviously they
wanted to do some kind of tests and just
you know figure out what a human being
was and at the time
if I had been brave enough to just stand
up and just open my window and go what
is going on out here
and for just have them to say you know
hey we want you to come with us and you
know we have tests and stuff we want to
do I would have gone
just knowing how I was at the time just
you know so interested in everything and
wanting to explore and experience
that I I would have gone 100 whether or
not they would have brought me back or
not I don't know but
I would have gone for sure
yeah
and to think about it now I mean
it's just
it's almost astonishing
for evolution
and then to have my uncle go through the
same experiences it's just
it's like mind-boggling man it's eerie
but it's not a bad it's I don't it's not
a bad thing though because you know I'm
alive they were they weren't coming to
kill you no they weren't coming to kill
me you know I still have had a really
great life
and
you know they they allowed me to achieve
that because at the time I I would have
gone nowhere
I would have just partied and just gone
down the drain and and been flushed out
but
how was that experience changed your
life of your behavior
you're working more I'm I'm more daring
definitely when it comes to travel
so this happened when I was probably 17
uh when I was around because this this
didn't stop my life this just added to
it you know like nothing changed it just
it just added to it and it just opened
my mind and just allowed me to think
more
yeah I just think it's incredible
for what can happen with Evolution I
know it's been about 10 11 years so I'd
give it maybe another
another 10 years or so
and then I'm curious to see what
happened because if it is real and I do
have you know extraterrestrial children
and they use my you know sperm to
harvest and recreate life and do
whatever you know I would really hope
that
those individuals wouldn't be
brainwashed enough to be able to come
back and try to figure out you know
where it all started
and maybe they would come back to me
and try to get them and maybe take me
with them or
maybe out of their own curiosity just
wanted to know what Earth was like and
and where their life
had started
and borrow some money yeah
yeah
some space money
all right Julius thank you so much for
sharing your story man thank you for
having me I greatly appreciate it
fascinating yeah thank you thank you